you know I was giving a lot of thought
to what I was going to do today on
garyvaynerchuk.com and I was kind of
stumbling you know a lot of my thoughts
are so similar and they're kind of
similar to the other videos I've done I
mean I can repackage them and give other
analogies against them and they'll
resonate and people think it's cool
because I think goodness always wins and
you know my parents have done the right
thing and gave me the right DNA to be
good but uh I finally just got inspired
very quickly and it hit me like a ton of
bricks like a thunderbolt through my
neck and this is what I want to do with
today's gary vaynerchuck I want to thank
every single person that has ever
watched one second has listened to one
word read one email did anything and
most of all watched any of these
garyvaynerchuk.com in their entire lives
because I will never like so many
internet celebrities or any kind of
celebrities or just normal people not
you can come in let's set it up um I've
got a table every TV I will never ever
ever take for granted the fact that
people take time out of their day to
watch what I do or listen to what I say
oh we're taking time to send me an email
or an instant message or a direct
message or text it is ridiculously
humbling and I think every person right
now that is having success with a blog
or video bloggers being followed by more
than your inner family and your soccer
friends should absolutely positively be
so grateful because we are we are not
only living in an amazing time where
it's possible at a very low cost of
entry to have this amazing network of
friends but we should never take for
granted the fact that other human beings
find us interesting and to me that is an
amazing gift and something I will never
take for granted so I kept a very basic
today I just want to say flat-out thank
you